now is not the time to let up we have a
lot more to do vaccine requirements that
we started rolling out in the summer
are working they're working every day
we see more businesses implementing
vaccination requirements
and the mounting data shows that they
work
just like there was that mounting data
that inflation was supposed to be
transitory or that mounting data that
kabul wouldn't fall to the taliban right
of course it depends on how biden is
defining the word success
sure most americans when they're forced
to choose between losing their jobs and
getting a vaccine they don't want well
they'll choose the latter
but parents need to support their
families after all they have to do that
people need to eat
but despite claiming to champion workers
rights democrats are showing their true
authoritarian colors on the vaccine
issue now the small small-minded control
freaks get a twisted thrill from having
all this power over people's lives
implementing these mandates creates
certainty it reduces uh the number of
people who are out of work california's
health care mandate uh working as it was
intended incentives the mandates
everything's working we're gonna keep
moving on that
when united airlines thinks they have
bragging rights because more than 99 of
its employees complied with their
vaccine policy like i wonder how many of
them felt like they had no choice
so much for the friendly skies
the airline says it's going to fire the
232 employees who said no
the fact is millions of americans have
heartfelt personal reasons for not
getting vaxxed including that many of
them have already had covet and thus
have natural immunity
they're not bad people for feeling this
way they're not stupid people either
it's their choice
nonetheless the bidet administration and
surrogates treat them as pariahs
some vengeful forces on the left even
revel in the fact that the vaccine
refuse nyx aren't eligible for
unemployment insurance
illegal aliens are getting better
treated
at a time when businesses are having a
hard time finding workers
the biden administration is ensuring
that more workers head to the sidelines
and its osha mandate results in the
firing of workers and our most important
and needed professions
i'm talking from health care to
education
law enforcement on down
as usual the effects of biden's policies
are felt most harshly by the regular
working class
northwell health the largest health care
provider in new york recently fired 1400
unvaxed workers
likewise christiana care novent health
and uc health system
in delaware north carolina and colorado
respectively cut more than 100 workers
each
and california-based kaiser permanente
just put more than 2200 employees
on unpaid leave nationwide
now it was obvious from day one that
pursuing these reckless mandates would
lead to mass firings and resignations of
health care staff we knew it would
happen
the totals by the way are staggering in
new york state alone roughly 34 000
health care workers have lost or quit
their jobs over the mandate
that includes over 20 thousand home
health care workers
and now governor kathy hokel is trying
to spin the shrinking of her state's
health care workforce by 3.5 percent
as good news yeah fantastic
our health care sector was already
stretched then we've heard this for
years and of course now it's
understaffed and now some hospitals are
operating shifts with skeleton staffs
pun intended
because who knows how many lives will be
lost or adversely impacted because of
these shortages we'll never know and
it's not just people's lives that are at
stake but their safety as well
today the president of the chicago
police chief union who will be with us
in moments issued an incredibly
terrifying warning about what's going to
happen when mayor lightfoot's vaccine
mandate goes into attack effect on
friday
teachers and school employees also face
the choice of getting vaccinated or
getting fired
about 8 000 new york city teachers have
been placed on leave for refusing to get
the jab
to the biden speechwriters though
they're just uninformed and partisan
vaccination requirements should not be
another issue that divides us school
board members
religious leaders and doctors across the
country are fighting misinformation and
educating people about the importance of
vaccines
and by educating people on vaccines
biden means punishing them and pushing
them into submission by making things so
painful they ultimately choose to relent
democrats inserted insidious provision
into their massive spending bill that
would give osha the power to levy huge
fines for each violation
i have to say though good for southwest
airlines ceo because he's speaking out
against these mandates
and it seems many of his pilots are too
by all those cancellations
perhaps the ultimate insult though is
directed at our troops
the navy is announcing that those
separated only for vaccine refusal will
receive no lower than a general
discharge under honorable conditions
now this type of discharge could result
in the loss of some veteran's benefits
of course the people who should be fired
though from positions
should be held accountable
they never are
people like mark milley anthony fauci on
numerous occasions they've been caught
lying breaking their word undermining
their professions
what consequences have they ever faced
zero
in fact the opposite happens instead of
being
reprimanded they're showered with
accolades
dr fauci is a hero for many of us i
would call general milly a hero
he he behaved in a heroic manner it's
always good to talk to you
thank you for a steady hand uh during
the crisis here in the empire state
at the same time those brave enough to
stand up and ask questions who demand
accountability from lieutenant colonel
stuart sheller to parents at school
board meetings they're targeted and
they're punished
in our upside down world grandmothers
who wandered around the capitol taking
selfies can face jail time
as george floyd rioters who looted and
burned entire city blocks run free
but americans i think i think they're
starting to wake up
that chicago police union head that i
mentioned earlier he's telling officers
to resist the city's vax mandate and
force the mayor to relent
pro-sports players are refusing to
denounce fellow
players who choose not to get faxed
i can speak about
myself
i think everyone has their own choice
to do what they feel is right for
themselves and their family
a few players are simply saying
no
i didn't take the vaccine at this point
in time the natural immunity is not
being spoken about or discussed in this
country what would you do
you know if you felt uncomfortable going
into the season uh when you were
promised that you would have exemptions
or that you didn't have to be forced to
get the vaccine
and brave college students even
professors are taking their fight over
mandates to court
ultimately the supreme court will have
to decide whether a century-old case
about smallpox is controlling here
my view that precedent is easily
distinguishable
cases are declining across america thank
goodness they plummeted 22 just over the
last two weeks
and the cdc
not doom and gloom for for once
predicting that positive trend is going
to continue
so there's absolutely zero reason for
any business to have any coveted mandate
in place whatsoever other than if you're
sick stay home
decisions to force employees off the job
are going to haunt businesses for years
to come just as they will haunt biden
and other politicians who insisted on
these mandates in the first place
the only people who should be forced out
of their jobs because of this pandemic
are the officials who kept america in
this prolonged state of fear and in
locked in these mandates
they cost us precious time precious
lives they wasted trillions of dollars
killed off hundreds of thousands of
small businesses
all to grow their own power and help
elect joe biden
and if americans could vote today
biden would hear those two words loud
and clear
you're fired
and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else